Mitochondria perform a really important function inside
cells. They produce boatloads of energy in
the form of a molecule called ATP,
or adenosine triphosphate. Without mitochondria, life as we
know it just wouldn't be possible. Now, a cell can have many mitochondria at a
time. Ranging from a few to several thousand. And each mitochodria has its own
mitochondrial DNA. Mitochodrial DNA exists in the form of a chromosome just like
our nuclear chromosomes, but our chromosome
here isn't linear, it's circular. One circular
chromosome in the mitochondrial genome has
only 17,000 base pairs. Remember all the
linear chromosomes of the nuclear genome have more than 3 billion base pairs.
The fact that mitochondria have their own mitochondrial DNA in the form
of circular chromosomes, is evidence that
supports a model claiming that mitochondria used
to be free living bacteria that were engulfed by an ancestral cell
and incorporated into our cells and thus our bodies, in an essential way.